visible to everyone so this is the t
bind for server which actually has
multiple sections where you can perform
various type of analysis depending upon
the data that you have then depend as
well as depending upon what type of
analysis that you want to perform so
this is very important uh platforms
this especially for both
uh people who have do not have any
bioinformatics background as well as for
those people who already have an
informatics background but as we know
that ngs data has very large data and it
is impossible to analyze such kind of
data on your own system so this platform
uh this platform offer you
the opportunity to give that
give this
interface to perform various types of
analysis without even if you don't have
much knowledge about programming because
here scripts are already executed so
then you just have to perform like a
click on button steps so you just need
to understand the logic
so for example here under the ngs data
you will find various sections like
transcriptomics that is bulk rna
transcriptomics then genomic section
then we also have a section that are
associated with micro rna or repetitive
elements under the dna and rna similarly
we have some of specific mutational
analysis section under the cancer
biology then uh
as we know that these days single cell
data analysis is like more days it is uh
so you will find specific section for
single cell data analysis similarly for
virolusi metagenomics and data mining
so now as we uh what we are talking
about genomics so one of the aspect that
so far uh dr agarwindo was talking that
is phallogenetic how we can
perform multiple sequence alignment so
let's first go over one of the sections
that is under data
integration and modeling here you will
find this data association and under the
data association sub section you will
find this
section specifically dedicated for
phylogenetic analysis so here when you
find this section that is means already
example pipeline or demo pipelines are
already given there so what we mean by
demo pipeline it means you need not to
upload any data so we already loaded the
data you you will understand what are
the steps that we can perform and how we
can integrate those results for example
let's take this example that is demo
wastewater
scope to msa that is multiple sequence
alignment so this pipeline where we are
comparing the samples that were taken
from particular scope to pixels
and
sorry scope to infected pieces uh not a
basin so here they have already
collected the waste water based water
data particularly from the uk where they
have municip samples
uh particularly available in the paste
water itself so we are going to this
demo
so by clicking on this
we just able to upload data
automatically where we already uploaded
raw sequencing files that were obtained
from
wastewater samples
so then why start we will able to upload
the data itself
so as the uh dr raghav was talking about
fastq files so they are the files that
obtain directly from the sequential
machine so they it contains the re
so then once you have the reads next is
how you are going to align your reach on
reference you know so for example here
we were talking about fast scope 2 so we
uh we were using a
reference genome for sars scope 2 and
with this
algorithm that is verti 2 but i2 so this
algorithm will align your rate on
reference genome so this is one of the
mapping algorithm
so then the next step which is
automatically get highlighted that is to
create the consensus so here you will
find first option which is getting
highlighted that is per nucleotide so
what is per nucleotide module so it will
create this kind of table where you have
sequence then corresponding atcc
positions
so then
um once you have those position then you
will able to able to create the
consensus sequences
so once you have the consensus sequences
then we can perform multiple sequence
alignment that which that will align our
consensus sequences that were obtained
from different samples so it
automatically aligns all those
algorithms
sorry all those sequences so
specifically here the uh algorithm that
perform multiple sequence alignment uh
that is omega w
so then once uh at the nucleotide label
you are able to align your sequences
so then next is
because to um to study the phallogenetic
analysis we also need to convert a
nucleotide sequence into the amino acid
so
here this particular module will convert
or
because on the reference genome we
already provided translational codons so
translational with the help of
translational codon so your nucleotide
multiple sequence alignment sequences
will be converted into the amino acid
next is you're just selecting the codon
position
so then uh
so after you're able to perform multiple
sequence alignment successfully next is
how you can generate phallogenetic tree
so you will find various algorithms here
itself like a
and then you have algorithm like beast
collision b speciation you will process
these birth death process so then
particularly most of the beast
algorithms not just consider the
similarity if they also consider the
time points so you can ah here we are
using this base patient birth death
process
uh algorithm to perform follow genetic
analysis or to generate a phallogenetic
tree
so then um once we able to perform the
steps next a step which is getting
highlighted here that is end so once we
able to end the pipeline
so uh we will uh
able to direct it to this interface
where you will be able to get the all
the output files since this is an
already an example pipeline so we are
immediately able to get the results but
yeah in case when you are doing all this
analysis on your sample usually it takes
sometimes depending on how many samples
you are uploading so it can take one or
two days if you have very large number
of samples if you are just using very
few number of samples in that case it
can take uh maybe one hour or something
like that
now let's look at what kind of outputs
that we will obtain
so let me first show you for example
following simple phallogenic tree so
here you will find even a pdf file
this is that pdf file
for example now you have this kind of
allergenic tree where you can compare
which sequences based on the following
tree you can understand which sequences
are more similar to each other or which
samples are more similar to each other
so the sequences or the samples that are
present in the same plate it means they
are more similar for example uh if i am
comparing these two um
for example these two samples they are
more similar in comparison to if we are
considering samples that are present in
different plates
apart from that if you have already time
point information in that case
the another very important uh
important information that we will get
that is like
which particular sample originated first
and uh
what are the other sequences for example
here in a phylogenetic tree how you can
understand so if you have uh
any sample that are towards the root so
here so those are the old samples in
comparison to if you have the samples
that are in the nodes so if this length
is larger
specifically for example these samples
might be the new one so then you can
compare if you have the date even the
time information then you can understand
which sequences are originated first or
which are originated later so you can
compare samples based on the phallogenic
tree just to understand which are the
evolutionary
specifically
phylogeny help us to understand what is
the evolutionary relationship between
different sequences
for example here we have reference
genome and this is also we just taken
another reference genome sequence just
to confirm whether the samples if they
are present in the same plate it
represent actually more similarity so
for this what we did we taken the
reference genome then we just uh taken
another reference genome just
we just re uh name it as odd group
sample so then when we are looking at
these two samples so they are present in
the same plate it also show or confirm
us like these sequences are more similar
to each other now let's look at the next
very important output so this is like
phylogenetic tree now how we can
visualize or understand these results
particularly at the level of multiple
sequence alignment right so these are
the like final results you cannot
compare but is the differences between
these so right now you know that these
sequences are for example
these two sequences are more similar to
each other in comparison to other
sequences so how do we understand where
are the what are the positions which are
different from each other so uh
what kind of analysis or from which type
of analysis we can understand that now
let's go back to our
output so first
output that you will obtain here so if
you look at here so i'm just reading its
name that is and steward it is msa out
uh underscore faster dot fa
so this is multiple sequence alignment
file at nucleotide label now let's
download this file and now let me
visualize this file using a freely
available tool that is eugene
so now let me open the ug
so this is the sample that we downloaded
right now so let's
open this
here
now we here we have multiple sequence
alignment at a nucleotide
label so this is uh what multiple
sequence alignment which we can
visualize using eugene now how we can
identify where our different sequences
or all these sequences are mutated or
there there is a mutation for example
whether you are considering with respect
to
reference you know or you considering a
specific sequence or a sample so how we
can find out where are what are those
mutations so on the eugene you will find
this option that is looks like a graph
so if you click on this
so here we need to select first that
reference sequence whether you want to
compare your data within with respect to
reference or whether you want to compare
your data for example with a specific
sample
if you have like you are considering
control samples right so i am comparing
my data with respect to the reference
you know
so this is also my reference genome
and i'm just uh
scrolling these samples
in this way so first i have to select a
reference genome if you select it here
just select this sequence then go to the
reference sequence
so here you able to select this
now how we can identify how many
mutations are there so we we can find
number of mutations as well as
percentage of a mutation let's look at
first simply number of mutations so here
um you for you can select this option
show distance column then you can go to
the count
so here you will find this column
four column
so these are the sequence name
and or sample names then you have the
score column that will
let you know how many mutations are
there in comparison to the reference
genome this is our reference you know so
how we can compare it so we can look at
for example this is the same sequence we
just named it different these are both
the reference genome so there are zero
mutations when you're comparing this is
the sample one there are seven mutations
this is sample two you we have ten
mutations similarly we have sample a ten
seven
here we have six mutations so this is
how we can look at how many mutations
are there now where are those mutations
we can always check that as well so if
you just scroll this
particularly you start scrolling this to
left to right you will also able to
identify the mutations for example here
so for this at this particular position
that is 9634
so you will find this a is getting
mutated to the t if you know that which
particular protein half the sequence
start position and position you can
definitely identify but at these
mutations so this is how we can look at
uh
how what we can interpret from the
phylogenetry then how we can on what we
can interpret from the uh multiple
sequence alignment itself is it clear to
everyone
or if anyone have any questions so far
okay daniel anyone else if you have any
specific question please feel free to
ask your question before
i move ahead
okay so if there is no more question
just go back to the server again so this
is just one example like if you have the
sequences you can do the phallogenetic
analysis to understand what is the
reason or what is the old sequences how
similar they are so then what are the
different of where and what are the
positions where mutations are taking
place you can perform uh those kind of
analysis using msa so then what other
options that we have for example we have
this is with respect to the viruses
then we have specific for example when
we are comparing cancer in the normal
sample let me look uh take one that kind
of example where we are comparing or try
to find out somatic mutations in the
cancer
so let us go over again here under the
genomics section so here under mutation
variant parallel analysis of mutation
variant data
let's take this cancer normal mutation
analysis
or i have simple uh
already results as well
so
yeah
so this is variant calling cell line
where we already computed some of the
results as well so under the variant
calling
um
here again
as this is an example pipeline so you
need not to upload any data here we
already provided one cancer sample and
one normal sample so we just need to
click on start
so with the start we able to uh
click on
able to upload the sample then of course
as we know that in the
ngs we need to perform uh important
steps like preprocessing particularly
here we are
first we are removing any pcr duplicates
using pcr clean the pcr clean then put
i2 to align or reads on reference
genomes of course here the reference
genome is human you know so hg
38 you know
so then with the starka which is one of
the algorithm uh particularly for
variant calling or indent uh in
small in that indulge detection
algorithm so we can find important
mutations
so then ah by clicking on the okay we
able to
calculate this
so apart from that you will find other
options as well so right now i'm
choosing stalker algorithm so then
somatic sniper
we are using semantics snipper which is
again a basin kind of uh bayesian based
region approach based method so which
compare cancer and the normal sample
then it determines whether a particular
mutation p so it will provide you
somatic score based on that particular
score you can actually understand
whether a mutation higher the score in
indicates that mutation is more
important so here we are using this
particular osmatic snipper algorithm
so then we can end the pipeline
so now again once we complete the
pipeline so we will automatically get
this output files
so i'm just downloading this zip folder
i mean by it is just downloading let me
look at if there is any question
in the chat box
okay so i have already opened uh one of
the
this
results in that cell so these are the
sematic snipper results so eventually
from this pipeline although we will
obtain the vca files if we analyze those
vcf files now let's look at what kind of
results here we have so this is kind of
a table where we able to compute the
result final results we have chromosome
fuji ship first we have a particular
chromosome then chromosome position then
what is the reference elite so exactly
what was the reference genius
referenced
reference
reference base or reference nucleotide
in our in case of the reference genome
so then we are comparing it with respect
to cancer in the normal sample so we
have this is
tumor sample and this is normal sample
now uh apart from atgc you will find
some of um other nucleotides here like r
g
y but it indicates so
keys so these are the substitution
mutations substitution means a of course
a could be
addiction mutation so then we also
represented for example m m indic again
indicates it is
addiction mutation where
in addition to a the c is also getting
added similarly you will find w there is
a t r indicate a z so these kind of
different positions corresponding
exactly what they represent
now based on the somatic score you can
understand whether or which particular
mutation is more important so let's uh
here apply a filter then just short our
values particularly based on somatic
snippers largest to highest so
larger the value of somatic sniper score
that mutation would be more important so
this is how you can uh analyze and
assess these kind of results
particularly from the uh mutational
analysis or mutation variant calling
method
variant calling methods apart from that
there are also the vca files that we are
going to talk about during this upcoming
genomics program where you can learn
like if you have vcf files how you can
assess uh
where are the what are the mutations in
a particular gene so how you can analyze
that and that is what we are going to
talk about in our upcoming session as
well as these things in much more detail
so yeah that's it if you have any
question i would be happy to answer your
question
uh no i will